All right, what's going on guys. This is Rob. And, um,
if those of you guys who are new to the channel here, uh,
it is Thanksgiving week. And that means that I give my guys the week off. Right.
I give them time to go spend time with their families and all that kind of stuff
because of the job that I worked at before I was a YouTuber,
I usually had to work on Thanksgiving.
And so I know what it's like to have to give that day up. Uh,
and I know what it's like to not be able to have that week to go spend with your
friends and family. Right? So because of that, on the main comments,
explain channel here, which is where I have all my staff basically working, uh,
they're going to be getting the week off,
which means that we're not really gonna be uploading any videos this week.
The only exception to that will be on Wednesday for a Patrion,
which is the vs video and Tuesday for Patrion, which is the uncensored video.
And this part, I think is the conclusion of Punisher max, uh, the slavers,
I think he's the one that we're finishing up. Um,
and so those videos are going to go on Patrion, but aside from that,
where it it's going to take the week off here, the next update here is discord.
Um, a lot of the guys who were familiar with the discord server and who've been
around the server for awhile, know a couple of different things.
The first thing is that the number of channels that we had was really just kind
of absurd, but between voice channels and, and we had channels for everything.
So we had like Marvel channels.
Then we had like X-Men channels and all that kind of stuff.
And the result was that we ended up expanding too far, too fast, right?
We were running our discourse server. Like we had 20,000 people.
When in reality, we only have about 5,000,
really about 5,200 at the time that we're recording this video.
And so what we did is we brought in a guy named Trent, who is the brother of a,
another, uh, I'm sorry,
a moderator for the discourse over Derek and had him basically comb through the
whole thing. And Trent gave us a lot of really good advice and said,
here's what you should condense.
Here's what you should do with all these different, different things.
And so that's what we did. Um, if you go to the discord server,
now you'll find an updated FAQ section and updated rule section. Uh,
you'll have to verify if you want to actually communicate on the discourse
servers.
So that way we can avoid people who are going in and trolling different things
like that and causing problems. Um, but you know, it,
it's one of these things where it's designed to kind of clean the whole place
up, right? Did it to kind of do a lot of house cleaning work, um,
as far as all the old channels that are not there anymore,
they are not deleted instead they're archived.
And what that means is that as the channel grows or as a discord server grows,
we can bring those channels back and all that chat history will be there.
So it's not gone forever, but it's not lost forever at the moment.
It's just down in the staff section where nobody can see it. Um, but yeah,
it's designed to clean the whole thing up.
So if you're familiar with the server, go check it out. Um, it's,
it's far more cleaned up than it was before,
and it's a lot easier to navigate so far. Everybody's loved it,
which is always a good thing. Um, and for those of you guys who are new,
you'll find a permanent link down in the description, uh,
to be able to access a discord server and hang out with me because every Friday
I do a, uh,
I do a Q and a section with you guys when I do a Q and a session where I just
talked to you all for an hour and a half, two hours,
usually about an hour or something like that.
And answer questions with you guys. Um, sometimes I give away Rob core rings.
Uh, we also have a bunch of different games and events, right?
We have quizzes that take place. We do versus battles on the discourse server.
So you guys can battle it out over who ends. Um,
we are kicking around a few other ideas and we'll actually make those known as
we get closer to when we're going to release those, there was different, um,
you know, engaging activities and so on. But, uh,
but that's where the discord server is right now. Now the final update here,
and this is the one that you guys are probably here for the selling of Rob court
rings. Um, I am officially selling Rob court rings,
and I know I've been I've, I'm probably a little late on this,
to be honest with you guys, I probably should have done this years ago,
but the biggest problem that I had was finding a way to sell rubber core rings
and keep up with demand because in years past,
if I had announced that Rog court rings were for sale,
I would have gotten hundreds of orders, right? Hundreds and thousands of orders.
And that would be a little unreasonable to try to keep up with. So, uh,
so if you guys are interested, Rob core rings are basically, uh, you know,
little literally rings that you wear. And in fact, I don't have mine.
I gave it to a fan Andrew when I met him for lunch the other day. But, um,
these are rings that you,
where they basically identify you as being part of the Robb courtroom, right.
So much by being part of the Robb court. Um,
I'm also gonna be having t-shirts stuff like that if you guys want to partake in
that, but, um, these rings are going to be sold, uh,
on a limited quantity, right? So, um, I only have sizes seven, eight, nine, 10,
11, and 13. I do not have size 12.
The place that makes my rings are currently sold out of size 12.
So as soon as those become available, I'll update the store.
But if you check the link down in the description right now, you'll find rod,
port rings are for sale. And, uh, and yeah, so once they're sold out,
you guys will have to wait until I update the store,
make another announcement or something like that. And, uh,
I'll let you guys know, you know, when those rings are available again.
So I imagine some of you guys are probably just going to hover around the store
every couple of days to see if it updates or not. Um,
I'm probably going to do this for, for the next little while,
maybe on like a weekly or biweekly basis. Uh, and just gonna, you know,
get you guys a bunch of rings.
I know a lot of you guys are sort of chomping at the bit to get your hands on
some. So, um, so yeah, I just want to make this update video,
let you guys know what's going on,
but you guys know how things are progressing and, uh, yeah. So anyway.
Just watching guys, please
[inaudible].